[Music]
ron's with us in
washington d.c hey ron how are you
hey dave i'm a big fan of since 07. how
are you
better than i deserve sir how can we
help i've got a quick question
sort of a philosophical spiritual angle
to things
um i know you guys have been you know
making this spending and living a legacy
i've got twin girls 14 years old i've
lost who knows how many jobs over the
past
you know a couple years i wasn't even
working a year ago now i am thankful
thank the good lord
i know you're big about saving and you
know for spending for you know
and saving for the future and but as
believers in christ
obviously we uh believe in the rapture
where our lord could come back at any
time
so say he did come back in the next five
minutes
all the money that you saved for you
know is kind of
not null and void but you know i'm not
saying why is saved because jesus is
going to come back and
we don't know in any moment does this
also make sense am i this crazy or am i
just
you know i'm not saying don't save but
i'm also saying that
you know say your christian members of
your family are not
you save your money for them because
obviously once they and again i'm
going a lot of things here in the
methodist background you go through the
tribulation period
you know and i've read you know tim
lahaye and jim jenkins books
you know that i i don't even know if
it's all making sense
well i mean there's kind of two things
pulling at this um yes
number one it's very good uh i think
it'll increase the quality of your life
while you're here and the the quality of
your decision making
on money and other things if you have
what you have which is an eternal
perspective
i'm not thinking of uh 50 years and i'm
dirt
okay you're thinking beyond that you're
thinking uh
differently than that otherworldly than
that and that gives you a
an advantage because someone who has the
broader perspective generally makes
better decisions
and so that's the beauty of an eternal
perspective
um then if you did within that context
you're you're kind of got two things
pulling at you
um one is that once we're dead
or raptured uh instantaneously money's
not important
and anything you've acquired is
instantaneously one second later
none of this matters right
right so okay wait wait wait wait wait
so
the point the point being that the
bumper sticker is right
he with the most toys when he dies is
dead which is kind of your point right
and then then the other side of that is
the wisdom
with an eternal perspective of living my
life
in a way that is mature that is
thoughtful and wise uh that does
leave a financial legacy for my family
behind
life insurance a will savings
paid for assets those kinds of things
which also line up
biblically without being inconsistent
with the other thing
so what we're saying is we don't we
don't rest our eternal hopes
on the stuff but proverbs does say
in the house of the wise are stores
this is the bible of choice food and oil
and a foolish man
devours all he has even if he used a
spiritual reason
to devour all he has and have no savings
he would be by biblical definition a
foolish man
exactly and so these two things appear
to be a juxtaposition with each other
while i and i think if you take a step
up above it you go
no they're not i'm not going to rest on
the
depth of my real estate portfolio i'm
not going to worship at that altar
and i don't want my kids to either
and so that's the eternal perspective of
idol worship and so forth
and on the other hand i've got this this
mandate
by my maker to be wise christie yeah
it's interesting because i think
sometimes we like to and you can apply
this to anything swing to extremes
and assume these things are mutually
exclusive and i think it's exactly like
you're saying dave we're going to hold
these two truths where
we're going to fix our eyes on internal
things our hope is in our eternal
destination and while god has us here
today
we're going to do what we can with what
we have where we are which means just
being a good
steward and so what we know today is
we're here
and we need money as a tool to fund our
lifestyle to take care of our family
after we're gone and so on so we're
gonna do that in the name of stewarding
god's blessings and we're going to know
exactly like you said dave our hope is
not in this this is not the
end game we have an eternal perspective
it's not either or
it's both you can hold both of those at
the same time
i was just going to say that i've heard
the phrase you know you're you're so
heavily minded you're generally good
yeah
and then on the other hand you're so
materialistic you forgot god
exactly that's the other end of that
right and so so
and really we don't even have to play on
that spectrum we can go up above that at
a completely different
point on the diagram and let's go
three-dimensional instead of a linear
perspective
between materialism and spirituality as
if there is
as if that's the only part of the
spectrum so i mean we're called all
throughout scripture to
manage things and love people
the minimalists were on the other day
and that's the title of their new book
love people
use things don't use people and love
things i heard that conversation
great it's a great title for a book i
mean because it just
it encapsulates everything that you
brought up and uh so what's the legacy
that we want these 14 year old twins to
have
we want them to have a high quality life
living here with wisdom which puts them
financially in a position not only to
take care of their own household first
or they're worse than an unbeliever
but also to be generous to widows and
orphans because they have the money
to be generous right to widows i'm just
going to say if they
and if the rapture comes then they're in
a higher place and not to worry about
the crap down here so let's
be happy to leave all of this behind and
let it burn
wouldn't make me mad at all i'm ready to
go come quickly lord jesus
i mean this it's crazy and crud out
there come quickly lord
but i i i don't know the day or the hour
and scripture's pretty clear i'm not
going to
and and so meantime i got to live with
what i got here and manage this thing uh
until i don't have to manage it anymore
and uh
and and the beautiful part about that is
the management of
stuff and keeping stuff in its place
spiritually is and transferring that
skill to your kids is character building
it builds your character builds your
spiritual character well well the
one thing i've learned is that they both
started summer jobs this this year yeah
you know rather than going during summer
camps they're working so much they're
making more than their father
you know who you know part-time stay at
home dead i've i've worked from home i
haven't even before the pandemic
yeah and i'm like your checks are more
than mine but but the thing is i've
noticed this with my younger daughter
she is more like we actually just this
guy's getting lunch she will go in order
for herself i'm like you want to come
with me no
she never did that before it's huge
character building date
yeah fantastic yeah it's and
see that's and what we're discussing
here is not the actual amount
it's what's happened in their hearts as
they've engaged in these act
in these earthly activities
how their spirits have grown right
exactly and so that's the that's this uh
weird
dance that we do uh as christians
and as people of faith that this weird
dance
between the earthly possessions if you
believe all earthly possessions
are evil and to own anything is
evil that is not actually a christian
track that's a track called gnosticism
and it was a is a toxic form a
heretical form of christianity that
popped up in the third century
i was going to say it goes back to the
ancient greeks exactly yeah and it was
born out of that but then they took it
and put it over
with an overlay on uh you know what we
would have called judeo-christian
ethic and and shifted it and so and then
that's that's translated into today's
world
with people who are ignorant of theology
and doctrine
who start to say things like well all
rich people are evil
because they have money oh and rich
people can't go to heaven which by the
way is
not in the bible but a lot of people
quote the bible that had never read it
and so this is a very interesting
discussion hey i appreciate you calling
in thanks for letting us
kick that can around with you because
it's uh you know it's something we don't
do often enough around here we should
stop and do that kind of thing good